el conflicto en territorio ucraniano no
se detiene pese a La tregua anunciada
por Rusia este viernes Club continuó sus
esfuerzos por avanzar en el este del
país pese al alto al fuego declarado
unilateralmente por Putin
el kremlin apuntó que las fuerzas
ucranianas realizaron cuatro ataques de
mortero en las posiciones rusas del imán
mientras que también dispararon rondas
de artillería en
bilogans y Saprissa respectivamente
esto provocó la denuncia de Moscú que
remarcó la postura reticente de que de
respetar la paz propuesta por Rusia
a pesar de que el ejército ruso lleva a
cabo el alto el fuego hoy 6 de enero a
partir de las 12 horas de Moscú el
régimen de kiev continuó bombardeando
áreas residenciales y posiciones de las
tropas rusas
sin embargo las autoridades ucranianas
denunciaron ataques enemigos pese a La
tregua
[Música]
según que hubo bombardeos en áreas
residenciales en gersón y kramators
luego calidad cercana-lugans y camino
back
los ciudadanos ucranianos no confían en
que el cese de hostilidades se respete
ni tenga buenas intenciones
Creo que este alto el fuego no tiene
sentido porque solo será otro intento de
Rusia de bombardear Ucrania
la propuesta de Moscú se debe a la
celebración de la Navidad ortodoxa pero
Igualmente fue criticada por occidente y
rechazada por Ucrania